I've known this about her for a very
long time you know so I'm very proud of
her Wilmer Valderrama praises girlfriend
Demi Lovato's emotional new music video
I can't imagine for you what that must
have felt like to watch it back just
because you have supported her for so
many years was that hard for you was it
emotional for you
no no we've been a lot of living being
in each other's lives for her entire
journey you know so so to syria ball by
such a multi-faceted artist to me it's
it's really you know what people needed
to see i love it you guys always refer
to each other as your best friends you
need this in this town you need someone
you can really rely on and you can
really trust one thing Wilmer couldn't
reveal about Demi is whether he's
planning on popping the question the 36
year old showed up to present his pal
Gina Rodriguez with an award at
varieties third annual unite for
Humanity event on Thursday I'm really
proud of her and really excited to say
some nice things about her and I'm going
for tearjerkers so we'll see how it goes
you